[Musica]
questo profilo è il modello della
sezione di un'ala si chiama profilo
alare e questo in particolare si chiama
gottinga 300 e 98 e la sezione di un'ala
di questo piccolo aereo da turismo
l'ala viene spinta verso l'aria che si
divide in questo punto che è il bordeaux
d'attacco e crea quella magia che si
chiama portanza e così abbiamo
banalizzato decine di anni di studi di
aerodinamica in una frazione di secondo
questo succede per gli aerei piccoli e
per gli aerei grandi per cui per esempio
possiamo andare in un luogo esotico in
vacanza a migliaia di chilometri di
distanza con poche ore di volo
naturalmente quando è possibile
aumentando l'angolo fra l'ala sempre il
flusso dell'aria si riesce ad avere
tanta portanza anche quando l'ala si
muove a una velocità relativamente lenta
come succede come deve succedere durante
l'atterraggio il decollo ma c'è sempre
un ma se l'angolo aumenta oltre un
angolo limite che si chiama angolo
critico succede un fenomeno per cui la
portanza a volte improvvisamente cessa
attribuiamo un nome a moltissimi
fenomeni e ovviamente questo che
capirete è di grande rilevanza non si
esime da questa regola e in italiano lo
chiamiamo stallo che parola strana che è
lo stallo si dice la formazione del
governo uno stallo la riunione è giunta
ad uno stallo ma anche in cose più
banali se facciamo una dieta la perdita
di chi li ha subito uno stallo associamo
la parola stallo all'immobilismo
all'anno nazione
eppure se un'ala a portanza e stalla
improvvisamente può solo fare quello che
può fare cioè volare balisticamente
verso il terreno precipitare o qualcosa
del genere
gli inglesi usano la parola molto simile
store
gli spagnoli invece usano per dida che è
un termine che evoca qualcosa di molto
più grave
tedeschi che sono sempre molto accurati
chiamano streaming hubrys che vuol dire
demolizione del flusso sempre molto
tecnico tutto sommato preferisco il
termine che attribuiamo noi non mi sono
presentato faccio l'astronomo
costruiscono telescopi strumenti che
lancio nello spazio magari alla volta di
pianeti o di come te oppure che montiamo
sui telescopi nei luoghi più reconditi
del nostro pianeta per esempio sulla
cima delle isole hawaii o delle isole
canarie o nel deserto del cile
dell'arizona o della california per
lavoro quando è possibile
mi muovo moltissimo con il traffico
commerciale e quando l'aereoplano fino a
quasi una decina una ventina di anni fa
quando l'aeroplano a qualche modesta
turbolenza in genere mi innervosisco
inizia a sudare apro il bocchettone
dell'area e di ciò ad esprimere magari
ad alta voce la mia opinione sul fatto
che forse non vale la pena tutto questo
rischio per gli specchi o le lenti che
stiamo cercando di studiare e ovviamente
i miei colleghi non perdono occasione
per dileggiare mi puntando il dito sul
fatto che le mie espressioni a volte
formulate in modo molto colorito e
cozzano contro l'evidenza statistica del
fatto che il volo il trasporto con
l'aereo commerciale rimane uno dei
sistemi statisticamente più sicuri e
così succede quello che neppure io
potevo assolutamente prevedere che molti
amici non avrebbero assolutamente
sospettato nel 2004 in un'estate di
piena solitudine diciamo sfortunato in
amore mi iscrivo così tanto per fare
qualcosa di nuovo e di strano di
cambiamento di vita mi iscrivo a un
corso di pilotaggio e per me è una
rivelazione guardare il mondo dall'alto
è una cosa fantastica magica ovvero
subito un vecchio vecchissimo aereo da
turismo assieme a due soci con i quali
perdiamo più tempo a ripararlo che a
farlo volare peraltro credo che con quel
piccolo aereo non siamo mai usciti dalla
valle del mugello da cui spiccavano i
primi voli e tutte le persone che si
avvicinano a questo mondo
chiedono magari impaurite che cosa
succede quando il motore peraltro molto
piccolo che muove questi aeroplani si
spegne l'aereo diventa una specie di
aliante non è un granché commediante ma
quello che serve in questo frangente è
tecnicamente si riesce a far atterrare
l'aereo anche in un fazzoletto di terra
e nel corso di pilotaggio
questa manovra simulata ma neanche più
di tanto anche se con a fianco un
istruttore pronto a prendere in mano la
situazione viene eseguita fino alla
nausea per quanto possa sembrare strano
la maggior parte degli incidenti letali
in questo mondo non avviene per mancanza
della propulsione che peraltro la baia
un fenomeno estremamente raro a parte
casi di errori grossolani come ad
esempio rimanere senza carburante ma
piuttosto perché durante il volo lento
magari proprio nelle fasi di decollo e
di atterraggio non si riesce a tenere
fra te e lo stallo tutti quegli quegli
intervalli quegli ostacoli quella
distanza che ti insegnano ossessivamente
durante il corso a tenere perché lo
stallo può essere anche qualcosa di
naturale
tu stai volando e magari stalla solo una
delle due ali e se stalla l'ala destra
per esempio l'aereo inizia
improvvisamente ad appuntare il muso
nella direzione opposta a quella in cui
stavo stai volando può essere molto
disorientando peraltro lo stallo è
risolvibile in un modo relativamente
semplice basta far precipitare
deliberatamente l'aereo per qualche
secondo in modo che questo prende
velocità e ricominci ad avere importanza
e questo è un agente
una mossa innaturale che viene insegnata
a fare al pilota in modo che eviti nel
momento in cui l'aereo sta perdendo
quota di cercare di mettere il muso
verso l'alto che aggraverebbe
ulteriormente la situazione ma anzi a
favorirlo ad assecondarlo è una mossa
innaturale che viene ossessivamente
insegnata all'allievo e che si
sintetizza nella frase che nel volo la
velocità è vita
e così arriviamo all'appuntamento con lo
stallo che nel mio caso accade alle ore
12 e 17 del 17 luglio 2011
l'appuntamento non è a samarcanda ma
massalengo vicino a milano in cui sono
passeggero di l'aereo di un mio amico
che sta pilotando io a quell'epoca era
già istruttore ma si tratta di un
semplice volo di divertimento succede
perché lasciamo precipitare una serie di
errori e ci corriamo a ripararlo solo
all'ultimo momento perché in questi
piccoli aerei nonostante siano più lenti
del traffico commerciale
in realtà volando piuttosto basso
rispetto agli aerei di linea
non c'è il tempo di rivedere il filmato
della propria vita come ci capita di
sentire nei passeggeri di qualche aereo
in cui avviene qualche emergenza
peraltro in quel caso qualcun altro sta
pilotando al posto tuo
mentre qui non è certo la situazione con
questi piccoli aerei tutto accade
maledettamente in modo veloce
l'aereo che stalla aereo che precipita
da un lato io che riprende i comandi
tutti questi aerei hanno i doppi comandi
come nelle scuole guida
l'aereo che riprende velocità che
riprende portanza è però purtroppo a
quel punto siamo molto bassi abbiamo
degli alberi davanti e mi risuona nelle
orecchie le parole che gli istruttori mi
hanno detto migliaia di volte e che io
stesso continua a dire ai miei allievi e
cioè che quando abbiamo siamo lenti e
abbiamo un ostacolo davanti cercare di
volerci sopra facendo alzare
ulteriormente l'aereo potrebbe essere
senza speranza molto meglio entrare
nelle chiome degli alberi piuttosto che
correre il rischio di installarci di
fronte o sopra ho meditato a lungo sul
fatto se avessi avuto l'opportunità di
riconoscere queste ore prima e sulla mia
evidentemente errata valutazione che
avvisare verbalmente il mio compagno di
volo che era i comandi fosse sufficiente
per risolvere la questione
non c'è niente da fare quando sei a 300
piedi dal suolo comunale in stallo non
devi pensare devi agire e così ho fatto
siamo entrati nella chioma degli alberi
la chioma attutito la velocità
dell'aereo un tronco ha strappato una
delle ali ci siamo adagiati a testa in
giù sul bordo di un canale i danni ai
serbatoi dell'aereo hanno fatto sì che
la benzina uscisse e non si incendiasse
siamo usciti non senza difficoltà io
quasi illeso il mio compagno di volo ha
avuto la necessità di qualche settimana
di ospedale qualche mese di recupero ma
siamo tornati tutti e due insieme a
volare il prima possibile perché rubando
un termine alla l'ippica il sella
ferisce sella guarisce per cui anche se
ho dovuto usare mi violenza ho cercato
il prima possibile di ritornare a volare
naturalmente il mondo è cambiato non
solo nel modo di volare
ora lo faccio in modo molto più accorto
è molto più razionale magari analizzando
ossessivamente le condizioni meteo o le
condizioni della pista in cui devo
atterrare oppure mettendomi
continuamente alla prova in condizioni
marginali ma in una situazione di
sicurezza per evitare di doverlo fare
improvvisamente di fronte a una vera e
genuina emergenza così impari che
comportarti in modo difensivo non
significa necessariamente fare un passo
indietro ma anzi riuscire ad avere la
consapevolezza di quando quello quello
di fare un passo indietro sia l'unico
modo possibile
quindi non smettere di volare
assolutamente anzi quasi volare ancora
di più ma farlo con una consapevolezza
di quell'informazione che fino a quel
momento tu avevi letto nei libri che era
stato raccontato da moltissimi altre
persone d'altro canto non possiamo fare
tutti gli errori possibili nella nostra
vita e che improvvisamente five
completamente tuo e il mondo tutto
intorno improvvisamente
assume un sapore completamente diverso
il improvvisamente tutto diventa un
bonus tutto diventa gratis
e così ti ritrovi a festeggiare gli
anniversari di questa rinascita fra un
po saranno dieci anni non vedo l'ora di
festeggiare la maggiore età e impari a
cercare di fare quelle cose che avevi
lasciato da parte che pensavi avresti
fatto in seguito e che rischiavano di
rimanere solo delle fantasie capisci
quant'è l'importanza del fare rispetto
al discutere di quanto sia facile cadere
in inutili ed infinite discussioni che
sono diverse da raggiungere un obiettivo
da raggiungere un risultato
e l'incidente come metafora di tante
cose che succedono nella vita quando
devi prendere in fretta la decisione di
fare qualcosa di male come gettarsi
nelle chiome degli alberi perché valuti
semplicemente che sia il male minore e
l'irrilevanza e le delle infinite
discussioni che si possono fare magari
seduti in un bar rispetto a quello che
era più o meno opportuno fare ed anche
l'inevitabilità di ciò che è bello il
fatto incontrovertibile che volare su un
aeromobile e guardare il mondo dall'alto
oppure osservare il cielo con un
telescopio che non è mai stato costruito
costruito prima celano al loro interno
delle cose così belle da rendere
incredibile questa pulsione ed è
impedire di non poterle continuare a
fare sono anzi siamo stati fortunati o
solo agito nel modo in cui nei manuali
di volo si può trovare alla voce
recupero dello stallo
avrei dovuto magari appendere la cloche
al chiodo come si dice in modo da
mettere nel modo più abbietto tra me e
la sorgente del rischio una radice
distante in modo da impedire
semplicemente di avere questo rischio
non lo so questa seconda chance mi
accompagna in visibile da quasi una
decina di anni e non sono sicuro di
averlo usato nel modo migliore
però sono sicuro incontrovertibilmente
certo di continuare a cercare di farlo
con tutte le mie forze